you've been on the show many times and
you're always dressed sort of like
Norman Reedus and now look at you you're
all dressed up I like it yeah we do have
this you kinda have to dress up down
here last time I was I think I wore a
poncho last month you did yeah last time
we did we did a show a week of shows at
comic-con in San Diego last summer and
you came to the theater you weren't
alone who'd you come with JD Morgan
that's right that's right you guys came
together on motorcycles now all of our
guests comic-con is insane there's
people all over the streets right you
got to come in a car with like security
you two decided to ride there yourselves
on your motorcycles yeah and the crowd
outside the theater which is just
hundreds of hundreds of people they
mobbed you it was insane were you scared
no I'm a really fast writer oh that's
right you wrote over them I forgot about
that we parked in the wrong spot
basically and then we got mobbed but I
triumph sponsors ride so I can call for
favors and get us bikes oh yeah so
there's pretty sweet yeah there's three
of us austin emilio also had a bike but
he didn't come with us did you just pick
up a phone wherever you are and say I
want a Triumph motorcycle
I forgot you know I don't my phone I
can't get an uber bring me a motorcycle
and they will do that for you
yeah okay
how much lead time do they need they
don't need any lead time they just
helicopter drop it there yeah I tell
them in advance yeah yeah especially San
Diego is so beautiful it's gorgeous it's
absolutely gorgeous I've seen it happen
fans the intensity of the fans that you
have is so great that it gets a little
off the charts at times what is one of
the weirder things that's happened to
you from a fan just pick something you
know I mean there's always the boob
implants I know that story's been it's
been out there for a long time you got
bit once didn't you
oh yeah yeah yeah well doc you can't act
like that just kind of thing just
happens you got bit by a fan yeah um
yeah like really bit um yeah I was
sitting there I was taking a picture and
then she kind of uh she kind of started
shaking a little bit and then she kind
of looked up at the sky got a hound like
a werewolf in the mint and she bit you
on the chest like real hard yeah like
left teeth friends and uh and Michael
Rooker is there and he goes oh that did
not just happen instead and then I state
the police escorted her out of the
building and I she I guess she got
outside and she said what happened and
they said ma'am you bit Norman and she
goes I did it and then I you know the
you know they were like you want to
press charges and I was like no she just
out of a moment she seemed like a nice
no hi I mean that's nice I'm glad you
didn't press charges that was nice
that's that's I mean I've never heard of
that I love that she went into some kind
of weird that was the weirdest fun feral
State and then before she bit you
and it kind of came from within it was
like good it was